hello and a very warm welcome to another
edition of talking germany the show
where we do just that and my guest today
is a man who is highly talented
charismatic passionate sometimes angry
restless outspoken and very very
versatile
here he is that man in person what's
classroom that was a good introduction
wasn't it well thanks a lot
he looked quite pleased with that now
ud's class he was a very bright
young man i'm not saying he's not a very
bright man these days but he was a very
bright young man
and he got one of the best school
leaving grades ever here in germany
that opened the way for a career at the
highest levels of corporate management
that included names like mckinsey
ford volkswagen and one of germany's
biggest companies the energy giant nbv
nbw to put it into the english he's also
an academic
and a business consultant he sold lots
of books and everywhere he goes he tells
people precisely what he thinks
and why for which they are not always
grateful to put it mildly he is i'm sure
going to be a fascinating
guest class and your first job is to
uh explain uh the german word for
a german word for our english audience
and that german word is
kve denka what is a coverdenker
a queer denca is a person who is
in a positive and constructive way
challenging
traditional thought flows
traditional ways of thinking who is
asking
innovative questions who is asking
unusual questions
and who tries to be innovative through
questions through questions and through
questioning
okay and what you say your your main
contention at this point in time is that
there are not enough of these people
these
verdenka these mavericks these people
who go against the flow
here in germany well we are a
society that is very well organized
that's one of our strengths
without a doubt the structures the flows
of processes are very well organized
but the price you pay for that is that
everybody
becomes a well-functioning part of that
organization
and over time that leads to the fact
that people
become so adapted to the organization
that they lose their own identity to
some extent and they lose
at least in the work process and they
lose
the readiness and the courage to also
challenge and question what's happening
in their organization and i always
believe that yes
we need to be part of an organization we
need to fit in within our organization
but we also need to maintain our
creativity and our dependence
of thinking and we need to maintain the
ability
to question what's happening every day
in order to contribute towards
improvements so what you're saying is
that
in in many ways germany is a little bit
complacent is becoming complacent is
becoming a little bit
set in its way that the successes that
germany enjoys at the moment
are perhaps in danger in the medium term
success is always in danger if you don't
change
because the world is changing rapidly
day after day after day
and the change process is continuously
being accelerated
so today if you keep your absolute
position
your relative position in the world
deteriorates every day
if you want to be leading edge leading
technology if you want to have
an adequate welfare system you need to
improve every day
to maintain your relative standard in
this ever
more complex world yeah but i mean
people
outside of the big wide world listening
to this listening to what you're saying
here
they will be astonished because they
look to germany as a country that is
is good at running its economy is good
at selling goods around the world is
is good at registering patents it gets
things right it's a problem-solving
country
and you're sounding like a sort of a
doom and gloom merchant who says that
you know
big problems are just around the corner
it's easy to say there are big problems
around the corner because they don't
have to arrive tomorrow you'll say well
i actually meant next year or the year
after let's say
for me i'm always interested in the
future in the time period which we can
still
impact upon and i see that germany has
been relatively successful in the last
10 years
and the question is how can we ensure
that we will be successful in the next
10 or 20 years
and our relative strength normally as i
said
is to react in a logical manner to react
fast to be stringent to be consequent
yeah to to to be rigid in what we do but
our strength is normally not
to be super creative to be super
intuitional
um yeah to to do positively surprising
things
and i think the world is going to change
and we also need to work on that
front and we also need to be even better
at exploiting our innovative potential
yeah we saw you there on that television
program when you were
17 years old wearing that yellow shirt
that lemon
shirt yeah when you see yourself in that
image what do you think
i think i had a few pounds less of
weight then
yeah it's probably true you know better
than i do yeah you made the impression
of being a super ultra
unbelievably incredibly confident young
man almost too much of a good thing
well i just enjoyed life life was not
very complicated then
i had just left school when that tv
program
uh was was live on on tv yeah
and uh after that i had a fantastic time
at hanover university and then a
wonderful
time at the university of oxford so that
was during a phase
within my life and i think within
everybody's life when you're
not even 20 years old when things are
not so complicated and you
enjoy the beauty of life well good for
you is all i can say but yeah
that joy that you are describing as a
young man and the confidence the
undoubted confidence that you had
you got that from your parents we're
gonna have a look at some images of you
as a youngster you as your parents
tell me about the values that they
passed on to you
well from my father
who has for has been a social democrat
for half a century
and whose parents died when he was three
in the year of 1916 i learned two
values which is tolerance and
equality of opportunity to everybody
everybody you're talking about from from
my mother i learned
never to be afraid of people always to
have respect
have respect for seniority for position
for
age but never fear and the highest
reflection of respect that i learned
from my mother is honesty
so never tell your boss or tell an
elderly person what they want to hear
always tell them the truth just one
second
class and as a young man again around
the same sort of age the
the the the favorite the golden boy of
all teachers yeah yeah
but that's a slightly misleading
headline because also
during school time i i asked a lot of
difficult questions and there were
teachers who i had a super relationship
with in in one case there's even a
friendship until today
but some teachers also found me very
difficult with all my
uh strange and difficult questions i can
imagine yeah
you chose with that with this talent
that you had and this self-confidence
that you had yeah
uh you chose to go into the world of
business yeah
and when you describe in your book which
we're going to have having a look at
shortly when you describe the world of
business what comes through
you talk about being let down you talk
about being deceived you talk about
bitterness you talk about an environment
that is in
unimaginably extreme that's what you say
you say if the people down
there down below knew what goes on up at
the top
then we'd have a serious problem in our
society why
is the world of business so shockingly
inhuman i think it's not only the world
of
business i think also the world of
politics has a lot of
disputable and critical qualities and
characteristics
and the system is very power oriented
and the system is very much reproducing
itself over time it's very much
reproducing the type of people who are
coming into top positions and very
frequently
it's not the creative it's not the
charming it's not the innovative people
but it's the power aware people who know
the rules of the game and
who know how to use the rules of the
game but there are other
examples and i think in germany we have
a say
give me give me an example of one top
politician in germany
at the moment to whom what you have just
said applies
the honesty the creativity or the lack
of honesty the lack of creativity
well switch on german tv at night watch
the news
and you will hear a lot of things where
the whole population knows
are we talking about the finance
minister the foreign minister are we
talking talking
about we're not criticizing individual
people
we're talking about the way what you're
saying is really damning of german
politics in fact
i mean i on a day-to-day basis and they
tend to be
pretty authentic honest people no we
should not give the world
a misleading impression of germany
politicians
all over the world are politicians and
we always dislike our own politicians
most because we know them better than
the others
so when i go to the us or to italy you
believe politicians there
and and the italians and the americans
will tell you our politicians are not
better
or worse than yours it's the same
everywhere i think it's the system
and the system leads to the fact that
politicians don't do
what's good for the next and the second
next generation
but what's good what's good for the next
election
and very frequently what is good for the
next election
is long-term damaging the interest of
the population
yeah that is the same in germany let's
go back to the world of business because
the world of business that you have
generally worked in down the years over
20 years was really the
corporate sector the the dax
companies the blue chip companies a lot
of the people that i meet in germany are
associated with the small and
medium-sized companies that are really
the backbone of germany's export
industry
they're totally different from the
people you're describing they're dynamic
they have flat hierarchies
they're people who are very very
inventive creative think outside the box
peter i also describe super good
managers like
ferdinand pierce or medon is another
example we have in this country like in
every country also very
good managers but again the problem is
the system
and the system does not like too many
questions to be asked
too many open discussions to be held too
many problems to be openly
discussed and confronted yeah the system
is
maintaining its position and i believe
that what we need is a culture of
sharing knowledge
instead of preserving knowledge as an
instrument of power
what we need is a culture of open
discussion
instead of no questions being allowed to
be asked
and what we need is a culture where
contradiction is seen as something
positive
in order to create innovation and
progress
and where conflicting views are not seen
as a
societal taboo
after the uh fukushima disaster a couple
of years ago angela merkel pretty
promptly came out and and said that she
had decided to phase out
nuclear energy here in germany by 2022
was she right to do so the
the decision you can view positively or
criticize
the process was scandalous because the
decision was taken within days
against the background of a regional
election in southwest germany
and every nation every political system
every people has the right to decide
whether it wants to work with or without
nuclear energy that's fine
but the radical changes that were made
should have been based on more
analysis on more facts on more
thought and we should not have rushed
into things just against the background
it's interesting isn't it with
with angela merkel people tend to
criticize her for sort of
for arriving uh decisions very very very
slowly generally speaking
because she looks to see what you know
what all the different lines of argument
that are that are out there
she also looks very closely to see how
the voters are
you know tuned into a story or not and
uh certainly on this one i mean
yes what you're saying is it was you
know it all happened very quickly
but she was right in line with german
voters
on this and still is yes but
having said that we have to also say
that one year after those decisions were
made
the then german environmental minister
altmeier came around the corner and said
the costs of the
energy vendor of the energy turnaround
could be
in total with other infrastructure costs
of up to
000 billion euro a trillion a trillion
and uh and well he called it one
thousand one thousand billion
a trillion and um i think if
a ceo of a large corporate company were
to withhold the fact for a year
that there could be a cost of a trillion
related to something he would be in deep
trouble
and that's what i criticize of
politicians in germany and abroad we
need more transparency
if they want us to follow the energy
turn around fine
but please based on all the facts and
not just on some of the facts
but you know as well as i do i mean you
know this figure that you are quoting
first of all there was an element of
sort of loose talk about it it was an
ill-advised statement
i don't think anybody was trying to sort
of hide anything
i think the the real problem is that the
german government hasn't got the
faintest idea
how much this 20-year project
is likely to cost that's the problem
well if you don't have the faintest idea
then you have to say that when you take
the decision
then you have to say ladies and
gentlemen we take a decision here
which could have multi-billion effects
but we do not have the faintest
idea and you want to follow us on that
although we do not have the faintest
idea sure you're right
let's imagine a company ceo would do
that he would be subject to a lot of
civil and criminal lawsuits is is there
or is there not
it seems to me that there what german
society your criticism
you're saying germany is still an
efficient country i think it is an
efficient country
two of the greatest achievements or no
the greatest achievement
in recent times here in germany i would
propose is
german reunification is by and large
making that huge project work and at the
beginning of that project which was also
a 20-year project
the government had not the faintest idea
uh
where it was going to go how much it was
going to cost how long it was going to
last but i think everybody pretty much
everybody in the country agreed it was
the right thing to do and it was a leap
of faith
that we were going to make with the
government two totally different
subjects
the german reunification a political
process
where you can never know upfront what's
happening
the energy turnaround within a political
area that is very well researched where
a lot of facts in interrelationships
are known and where flood affects were
deliberately ignored
like for example the implications on the
co2 emissions
because at the time that happened the
german number one
environmental policy goal was still
reduce
co2 emissions and we now see and it was
clear that it would come
we have the highest level of lignite
um league night use in in
electricity production in germany since
24 years ago
and we have increasing co2 emissions and
that that would happen was crystal clear
and no politician or hardly anybody said
it clearly to the population
so i'm not against the energy turnaround
it's a fascinating process
i'm in favor of innovation i'm in favor
of taking
certain risks but i'm against taking
irresponsible risks
and i'm against not creating and
and ensuring the biggest transparency
possible for the population
germany is a fantastic country yeah but
my job as a german citizen is to
contribute to where we
can get better in the future instead of
sitting and lying back and being happy
how good it is
okay uh the one thing i think we would
agree on is that this project is daring
that's for sure it's a there's a huge
element of risk about the project
you could say that it's a pioneering
project and i think around the world
certainly in a place like japan they're
looking very closely
at what whether germany can make this
work
because that would send out signals to
cut other countries
that you can move from fossil fuels you
can move from nuclear
energy sources to renewable energy
sources and my question to you is
because i know you know the business
um is it going to work i mean aside from
you know all the
politicking is it going to work i
believe that we will
in this century reach a stage where the
world will go
into a global regenerative solar
wind-assisted energy world which is
purely regenerative and where we will
not depend to the slightest on fossil
fuels
but i also believe that the german way
because the world is interconnected and
climate protection doesn't stop
at the border between germany and the
neighboring country
we will see that the german way of the
energy turnaround will increase co2
emissions
will increase electricity prices in
germany
and will become a burden for german
industry for
a certain period of time
well a lot of young people here in
germany complaining about their lot
are they justified look i
i very frequently visit spain because
i'm also
invested into a spanish professional
football club and i've spent many years
in spain and i love spain i really love
spain and the spanish
but if we look at southern europe we
have a youth unemployment rate
of up to more than 50 in some extreme
cases up to
60 65 66 if
two-thirds of a whole generation get a
feeling that there are no perspectives
for them or the perspectives are
vanishing
that is a societal catastrophe and i
think that
is the key european challenge if we
believe
that the european family shall function
and i also address this in in my book by
the way not troublemaker
but uncomfortable is the title a
troublemaker mr uncomfortable
as well so so my english teacher would
be very surprised
but anyway in my oxford tutor as well
but anyway no this this is
the european challenge we cannot accept
that two-thirds up to two-thirds of a
generation
in an important region of europe is
losing its perspective
a messiah was very surprised after the
angela merkel formed her after the
recent election here in germany she
formed her new government and then they
declared what government policy was
going to be for the years to come
and they were i had imagined that angela
merkel would opt for some kind of
pan-european program to support the kind
of things your
you know efforts against youth
unemployment and what have you didn't
come
two questions first of all um i suppose
why when you're describing the extent of
the problem in spain which is something
you know about
i i wonder why young people in spain
aren't angrier
they are angry but spain is a country
where the value of the family
is still exorbitant it's enormous and it
has
a strong catholic quality
so you have the family structure and the
catholic belief
and the two things interlinked absorb
the problem towards a certain limit
if in london or berlin or new york
we had 65 youth unemployment it would be
difficult
to walk on the streets without some
security protection
and in spain people are still very
patient because the family is absorbing
a lot of the problems
but that will only work for so long and
not forever
on on the german politics in spain there
was a very heavy reaction towards the
pension reform in germany
because the spanish reaction summarized
in a sentence was
how can it be that the same politicians
and the same chancellor
who imposed the change from 65 to 67
years on
spain gives its own people a change from
65 to 63.
and now as a german you could say we can
afford it but it's not only a question
of whether we can afford it
if we believe in a european family this
is not a good development
okay and if and if angela merkel were to
come to you and say oh it's class and
you
you know about business you know about
spain you know about the problem in
spain you've just described it
and say what should we the german
government do what can we do i would say
change the euro protection program
totally
so far the policy has been the euro
is uh in high risk so let's send
checks to the intensive care station to
rescue it
my view is if somebody in the family is
ill you don't send a check to the
intensive care unit
but you visit the person you talk to the
person you assist the person
and with southern europe they need
infrastructural help we need to
intensify academic
links we need to improve education also
the professional education for people in
on in the jobs and on the jobs
whereas there's all types of
infrastructural support that we can give
instead of just sending checks to the
south yeah but of course you say all the
time we should be telling the truth to
the german voters
it would cost a pretty penny it would
cost an awful lot of money and i don't
know if the german voters would go with
it
yeah but i think that discussion has
we have to have because the honesty is
the challenge
in europe is bigger than we think it's
not small
and it will be more costly than we think
and either we
are prepared to invest into the future
of the european youth
or we will pay an even higher political
price
well that is the question isn't it is
the this whole these fair play
regulations that are going to be
introduced are they going to give
european soccer
a level playing field yes or no
hopefully
hopefully but i think it's not the key
issue because if mr abramovich were to
give a hundred million from his private
fortune into the football club i don't
see that
as a major problem it's a much bigger
problem if club responsibles
abuse the money of thirds of third
parties or third people
and if they burden their clubs with tens
or hundreds of millions of debt
and if they take irresponsible actions
for which they have not put in the money
and i think i i therefore believe that
it is indeed
a key task to ensure that the finances
of professional clubs are in order
are professional are transparent but
equality is a nice topic
that i appreciate but order
correct numbers no debt and not spending
more money than you have is more
important than
you you're sounding you're sounding very
germany you're sounding almost like
wolfgang scheible the german finance
minister sort of lecturing to uh to
other european countries into
in the eurozone crisis but and i think
what you're saying is it
you know it's a clear message uh and the
the uh
at this present point of time there's a
lot of debate about the the sort of the
germans on this and not just in germany
are being portrayed as the good guys
they're getting it right onto on the in
terms of the way they manage the
business model they have for their clubs
are the spanish football clubs like the
one that you are responsible for
as well they're involved with with your
holding are they the bad guys
in spain well we have had the world cup
of 2006 and i'm all against
lecturing others because uh there's no
reason for lecturing when i came into
hanover
and my successor was just in your film
when i came into the hanover football
club there was a lot of debt in hanover
in germany the situation has improved
dramatically with the 2006 world club
cup and all the stadium infrastructure
around it
and there was a lot more turnover and
income generated within the new stadium
infrastructure afterwards
today very clearly the spanish league
has
and the spanish clubs by and large have
more financial difficulties
majorca is one example for that
it's been a few very very difficult
years and i have had to
invest a lot of time into transparency
and and reducing that debt and
and ensuring the highest level of
integrity and it's still a difficult
struggle
but i think germany has other problems
and
we have benefited a lot from the 2006
world cup
and with the german stadium
infrastructure spanish football would
have less problems
okay that's a good answer um you don't
just invest
in soccer you invest also because we're
talking about what you do these days
we've looked at what you did in the past
you also invest with a startup company
in broken bones
and you've got something here yeah i
invest in i have invested in a
company which is engaged in
bioabsorbable metallic implants
we have we are the first company in the
world
and the only company in the world up to
today which has received a ce approval
to be allowed to market this product in
30 european markets
it's a metallic compression screw which
is bioabsorbable
so after a certain period of time it is
being dissolved and that means that the
second
operation the second surgical operation
for removing
the implant becomes obsolete which can
and should hopefully mean half the time
half the risk half the pain
half the infection risk to millions of
patients
who could do without a second operation
in the future
we have introduced the product into the
german market
in summer 2013
and in within 2014 we have started our
first export markets
and we are just on the process of also
starting to export outside europe
okay it sounds very promising i have to
say interesting stuff
uh i've got to ask you two questions
though before we we're getting sort of a
little we're getting close to the end of
the show one of the questions i'd like
to ask you is um
is what would your advice be to the 17
year old
class and when you look back and you see
that young lad on tv
yeah knowing what you know now as
somebody who's now
just beyond 50 what would your advice be
to the to the young man
to to do what he regards as right to
always
follow certain values of truth honesty
and consequence
um i i would advise him in
in today's world maybe to study
astrophysics because the world
outside or let's say the universe
outside our planet is so
fascinating and i restricted myself to
management studies economics medicine
and industrial design i would say to the
young
class maybe you should also go for
astrophysics okay
and my other question that i do that i
really really want to ask is that you've
you've implied and i know you've said
this out outside the show
you you've published your intention to
go into german politics
and today you've you've indicated that
you're not happy with the way the
politicians are doing things you want to
sort of what could be described as a new
approach possibly a populist new
approach
when are you going to declare your
intentions proper
at the right time which is still being
at the right time which is
we're talking about before the end of
this year
we are talking before being too old and
within still being and still being
credible
in front of the announcement i made not
so long ago i said on a german tv show
we need
liability for politicians like for
managers and everybody else
the support was fantastic okay okay
we'll have to wait and see i
uh i for one am uh i'm very intrigued to
see whether what comes of what this man
has been telling me about german
politics
he's eloquent he's outspoken he's
passionate he's arts class and he's been
a
great guest if you've enjoyed his
company as much as i have do come back
next week until then bye bye and
you